WE HAVE REPORTED IT BEFORE.
I DID A SPECIAL ON IT.
WHAT DID YOU SAY?
YOU CAN GO OUTSIDE.
YOU DON’T NEED A MASS IF I CAN
YOU’RE AND PEOPLE VACCINATED
OR NOT.
UNLESS YOU ARE STILL IN REALLY
CROWDED STADIUMS AND ARENAS.
SHE IS STILL SUGGESTING EVEN
WITHOUT A ONE, IF YOU ARE CLOSE
TOGETHER AND YOU MIGHT WANT TO
WEAR A MASK.
INDOORS, DR. WALENSKY SAID
SOMETHING WE THINK IS
IMPORTANT.
IT SPREADS WELL INDOORS.
SO IF YOU ARE AROUND PEOPLE
WHO ARE NOT VACCINATED SHE
HIGHLY RECOMMENDS THAT
EVERYBODY WEAR A MASK IN THAT
SITUATION.
THAT IS WHAT I GOT OUT OF IT.
BUT LET’S GET THE NUANCED
ANSWERS OF THOSE WHO HAVE BEEN
SAYING MUCH THE SAME THING FOR
QUITE SOME TIME.
TOMI LAHREN?
>> Tomi: AGAIN, I’M GLAD SHE
IS GIVING US PERMISSION.
YOU KNOW IT’S FINE TO ISSUE
GUIDANCE AND TOTALLY FINE.
I THINK PEOPLE WANT TO HEAR
FROM THE C.D.C. AND THEY WANT
TO HEAR THE GUIDANCE.
WE NEED TO GET TO THE POINT IN
THE COUNTRY AS WELL TO LISTEN
TO THE GUIDANCE AND PEOPLE CAN
HAVE THE PERSONAL
RESPONSIBILITY AND THE
PERSONAL CHOICE TO MAKE HEALTH
DECISIONS FOR OURSELVES.
IF WE FEEL GOOD TO WEAR A
MASK, AND IT MAKES US FEEL
BETTER AND SAFE, WEAR A MASK
UNTIL YOUR HEART IS CONTENT.
ONE, TWO, THREE, FOUR FIVE.
BE FULLY VACCINATED, SLEEP IN
A MASK.
I DON’T CARE.
BUT WHAT WORRIES ME ABOUT THIS
IS PUSHING PEOPLE TO GET
VACCINATED AND DANGLING THE
CARROT IN FRONT OF THE FACE.
YOU CAN LIVE A NORMAL LIFE IF
YOU GET VACCINATED.
I’M SORRY BUT IT MAKES MY EARS
PERK UP AND IT MAKES ME
UNCOMFORTABLE.
I DON’T LIKE TO HEAR THAT.
I DON’T LIKE TO DANGLE THE
CARROT.
PERSONAL DECISION.
PERSONAL RESPONSIBILITY.
GET INFORMATION AND LET PEOPLE
MAKE DECISIONS FOR THEMSELVES.
>> Harris: KAYLEIGH?
>> Kayleigh: IN THE GREAT
STATE OF FLORIDA I FELT I WAS
WATCHING ALTERNATE UNIVERSE
FROM THE BIDEN ERA C.D.C.
TELLING US WE ARE ALLOWED TO
GO TO CHURCH NOW?
PRESIDENT TRUMP DID A PRESS
CONFERENCE MANY, MANY MONTHS
AGO.
WE’RE ALLOWED TO GO TO
RESTAURANT?
IN FLORIDA WE NEVER STOPPED
GOING.
THERE WAS A SHORT PERIOD OF
TIME WE DIDN’T UNDERSTAND
COVID AND IT MADE SENSE TO
SHUT RESTAURANTS BUT AS
QUICKLY AS POSSIBLE WE
REOPENED THEM AND DID SO
SAFELY.
WEAR MASKS IN A DEZ LATE
FIELD?
THIS IS A BASIC COMMON SENSE.
THIS IS ACCEPTABLE AND IT
SHOULDN’T BE A BIG
ANNOUNCEMENT.
WITH REGARD TO THE C.D.C.
UNDER PRESIDENT BIDEN THEY HAD
A ROUGH TIME OUT OF THE GATE
WITH WALENSKY TELLING US YOU
CAN GO BACK TO SCHOOL EVEN
WITHOUT ALL THE TEACHERS
VACCINATED.
THEN THE TEACHERS UNION AND
HAD AN ERUPTION AND SHE WALKED
IT BACK SAYING SPEAKING IN THE
PERSONAL CAPACITY.
WHATEVER THAT MEANS.
SHE SAID YOU CAN’T GET COVID
WHEN YOU HAD THE VACCINE EVER
AND SHE WALKED THAT BACK.
SO IT’S ROUGH GOING OUT OF THE
GATE FROM THE C.D.C. DIRECTOR
WALENSKY.
>> IT’S HARD, I IMAGINE.
SHE IS NOT A POLITICIAN.
SHE IS JUST TRYING TO TELL US
WHAT SHE THINKS IS GOING ON
BASED ON THE SCIENCE.
IT’S COMPLICATED IF SOMEBODY
HAS AN AGENDA.
>> Charlie: RIGHT.
THAT IS THE GREAT THING ABOUT
THE POLITICIANS.
THEY HAVE ALL THE ANSWERS.
THEY DON’T HAVE SOME ANSWERS.
>> Harris: THEY USE ALL THE
WORDS.
>> Charlie: EXACTLY.
THE REAL PROBLEM HERE, I TELL
EVERYBODY, THIS IS GREAT TO
HAVE THE GUIDANCE FROM THE
C.D.C.
GREAT TO HAVE THE C.D.C.
SHE IS PROMOTING VACCINE
HESITANCY, SAYING GET A FULLY
VACCINATED AND YOU STILL CAN’T
BE INSIDE WITHOUT A MASK.
>> Harris: AH!
>> Charlie: THAT PROMOTES
VACCINE HESITANCY.
THAT IS WHY SO MANY PEOPLE IN
AMERICA TODAY --
>> Harris: INTERESTING.
>> Charlie: I LOVE VACCINE,
I LOVE MEDICINE, I LOVE
SCIENCE ALL THAT STUFF.
BUT IF THEY ARE TELLING ME IT
DOESN’T WORK WELL ENOUGH THAT
I CAN DITCH THE MASK AS SOON
AS I’M FULLY VACCINATED I’M
SUSPICIOUS ABOUT THAT.
>> Harris: WELL, YOU KNOW
WHAT?
THERE IS NO ZERO POINT FOR
RISK IN LIFE.
>> Charlie: RIGHT.
>> Harris: EVERYTHING HAS
RISK.
>> Charlie: AMEN.
>> Harris: IF YOU GET
VACCINATED AND YOU ARE NORTH
OF 90%, THEN TOMI, IS RIGHT.
IT’S GUIDANCE THAT YOU CAN
TAKE OR NOT TAKE.
BASED ON YOUR OWN LIFE
EXPERIENCE.
EMILY?
>> Emily: RIGHT.
MEMBER THE WHOLE PURPOSE OF
THE LOCKDOWN -- REMEMBER, THE
WHOLE LOCKDOWN IN THE BEGIN IS
FLATTEN THE CURVE.
>> Harris: ISN’T IT FLAT
NOW?
>> Emily: IT WASN’T TOO --
RIGHT.
IT WASN’T TO ERADICATE ACTUAL
INFECTION.
SO IT’S AN INTERESTING DATA
POINT WE KEEP CIRCLING AROUND
AND WE SEEM TO IGNORE.
IT’S INTERESTING SHE WAS
POINTING TO AND SHE KEPT
POINTING TO THE EFFICACY OF
THE VACCINE TO UNDERSCORE AND
DEMONSTRATE THE POINT THAT YOU
THEN NEED TO WEAR A MASK
INSIDE.
SHE IS LIFTING THE
RESTRICTIONS.
NOW YOU CAN GO OUT INSIDE
WEARING MASKS.
MOST STATES ARE DOING THAT TO
KAYLEIGH’S POINT.
CHARLIE’S POINT, THEN WHAT IS
DIFFERENT?
TO TOMMY POINT, THIS IS AN
INTERESTING QUESTION THAT
RACES THE ISSUE OF THE
ENFORCEMENT.
SO IF THE GUIDELINE AND THE
RULE IS YOU CAN GO OUTSIDE
WITHOUT A MASS IF I CAN YOU’RE
VACCINATED HOW DO YOU CHECK?
HOW DO YOU KNOW?
DOES IT MEAN THAT THE BUSINESS
AND THE LOCAL COUNTY WILL SAY
SINCE WE CAN’T DOUBLE CHECK
AND WE DON’T KNOW WE’LL MAKE
EVERYONE WEAR A MASK STILL?
DO WE REQUIRE VACCINE
PASSPORT?
THE QUESTIONS THAT GET RAISED
WHEN YOU TALK ABOUT THE
KNOWLEDGE OF IT THAT LEADS TO
THE ENFORCEMENT.
I WONDER HOW OUR GOVERNMENT
WILL NAVIGATE THAT?
>> Harris: WOW!
YOU KNOW, I READ AN ARTICLE
RECENTLY THAT TALKED ABOUT THE
EFFICACY OF THE FLU SHOT AND
IN SOME CASES IT’S ROCKING
LOWER THAN 40%.
WE HAVE VACCINATIONS NOW THAT
ARE MORE THAN DOUBLE THAT.
I HAVE NEVER HEARD THAT
GUIDELINE TO WEAR A MASK IN
FLU SEASON.
HAVE YOU?
>> Charlie: IF YOU AND I HAD
90% ODDS WHERE WOULD WE BE?
WE’D BOTH HITCH A FLIGHT TO
VEGAS AND STAY THERE FOR A
WEEK.
>> Harris: THEN I WOULD